confirmation proof of live stream i call
it
we'll see if anybody is out there please
let me know if you can see myself
with my illustrious guest amy morin
uh waiting for this to get confirmed and
then we will
start the start the non-madness
hopefully this will not be mad
this will be conventional this will be
nice and and calm
i'm still waiting to see if we
do or do not have our
our guest here i mean our
live stream here let's see here i don't
see it on here
uh maybe 20 people are in the live chat
that's okay
and i'm waiting sorry amy sorry
no problem um waiting to get to see if
this
stream is working it says we're live but
i don't believe it until i
see it so let me check here let me check
it should show us all right we're live
we are live and it is a great pleasure
to have
the legendary amy [ __ ] visiting us from
somewhere
off the coast in international waters
avoiding santa claus at all costs amy
how are you doing today
i'm well thank you how are you i'm doing
great although like
many parents i am getting nervous uh
although
not nervous for my holiday season we're
jewish so that passed so i
i got that out of the way although it
was eight times as difficult as my uh
gentile friends are going to be enjoying
but i wanted to talk to you today uh
about your wonderful book
13 things mentally strong parents don't
do
because of the following event that is
coming up i'm told
tomorrow which is the following
conversation is about to be had
in millions of households around the
world mommy
uh for christmas i wanted x
let's call it x a toy that's frivolous
it's highly breakable has many
components requires 17
9-volt batteries that don't come with it
uh but you got me this
thoughtful brain expanding toy why did
you do that mommy i really wanted
that frivolous breakable highly
inconvenient toy why did you do that
as a mentally strong parent handle that
situation
oh good question so i think the best
place to start
is to acknowledge your child's feelings
even though you might think that their
disappointment
or their anger their sadness is out of
proportion
because party is going to say well you
just got all these other toys why are we
being ungrateful but that's sort of the
last thing you want to do is point out
that
that you don't like their attitude
instead you're going to start by
validating their feelings ah
i think you're really sad right now i
can see you're really angry
whether you agree with it or not you
don't have to these are their feelings
so you can
acknowledge those feelings and then say
what do you think you should do about
those feelings and it's a great
opportunity to coach your kids maybe
they need to go calm down for a few
minutes maybe they need to
take some deep breaths and figure out
whether they want to play with the toy
you got them
or not either way uh that it's okay
and i think to be able to use that as a
chance to let kids know yep life can be
disappointing sometimes we don't always
get what we want
but here's what we're going to do about
it without using those exact words as
tempting as it might be to
to tell them fine i'll return all your
other toys or when we have this
knee-jerk reaction of
i'll get rid of everything if you aren't
grateful for it it's not helpful either
so you just want to validate
your kids feelings and then say what are
you going to do about those feelings and
then coach them
uh and how to deal with them yeah very
good and then uh when
when you think about the holiday season
it's it's a season so it lasts for
for quite some time and i will always
wonder you know kind of
what is the best plan of action should
we try to have uh
you know stamina or should we try to you
know kind of
put it all out there for the for the 24
hours that are about to happen with
christmas or
um or then and followed by new year's
followed by
covet lockdown for many of us how do we
pace ourselves and become mentally
strong
yeah so i think sometimes people think
that pushing forward at all costs is a
example of mental strength that if
you're running a marathon and you break
your ankle halfway through you're
mentally strong if you keep running on
that broken ankle but that's not the
case
often it takes more it takes more
courage and strength to say uncle and to
back off and to say i'm going to take
care of myself so i think it's all about
the balance if you have a lot of plans
and a lot of things going on
in the future how do you take care of
yourself now and for some reason we
don't question that our devices have to
be charged our laptops our phones
and we just know that we've come to
accept it by the end of the day your
battery is going to be dead and you
better plug it in
if not sooner than the end of the day
but yet when it comes to ourselves we
tend to think oh i don't ever need to
stop and slow down and rest
but that attitude is what gets us in
trouble so i think no matter what kind
of holiday season you're facing to make
sure that you're
taking plenty of time to take care of
yourself is super important
and i want to just welcome people we had
a couple of hiccups with the stream in
the beginning and actually did not post
to the correct
link but welcome everybody who is
watching out there
on dr brian keating youtube we're trying
to work through these things but i do
want to point out
that we are talking to the incomparable
amy morin who
is an inspiration to millions of parents
and
people even without kids i know that for
a fact
around the world and she has done and
accomplished many things including
writing
really uh an incredible series of books
that have
made me a better person and made me a
better parent and for that i thank you
in this holiday season amy
i also want to point out that i am going
to be matching any donations
received during this uh during this
livestream two to one for the
make-a-wish foundation which is a
charity that
amy and i both love and support so it's
needed more than ever in these
very challenging times that we are all
experiencing not just the holidays but
uh
but for example we are experiencing uh
an incredible challenge to parents and
to children
and i i wanted to ask you what advice do
you give to
uh children you talk a little bit in the
book 13 things mentally
strong parents don't do about you know
talking to your kids about terrorism and
school shootings and stuff like that
how would you say you would have updated
it or would you
based on the situation with covid19
oh i certainly would update it because
it's another prime example of
how parents can teach kids in real time
we don't just have to talk about the
what ifs but now we're saying okay what
do you do with this
and i think the most important message
is that parents send it to kids that you
acknowledge this is a stressful time but
we're going to get through it
i hear so many parents and sometimes
even teachers talking about how
traumatized their kids are because they
can't play basketball this year
and it makes me cringe because it's not
traumatic to miss basketball season and
you know not to shed light on the fact
that
this experience could be traumatizing to
some kids kids that are being abused at
home
or kids that have really unhealthy home
situations or they don't have enough
food to eat
that absolutely could cause trauma but
the pandemic itself isn't what's causing
trauma or missing out on a sports
activity isn't traumatic instead it's an
opportunity
and if we just turn that around as a way
to teach kids yeah this isn't what we
wanted this isn't the year we predicted
if we could change things we would
but we can't this is the hand we were
dealt so here's what we're going to do
with it and
it's okay for parents to acknowledge
that they're stressed out or that
they're uncertain
and while you don't want to burden your
kids with all the stresses of your
financial situation or you don't want to
talk so much about
uh the state of the world and this and
that it's okay to let them know yeah i'm
stressed out so i'm gonna go to my room
for a few minutes and read a book
or uh you know my i just need a break
we've had so much family time sitting in
the same room together all day long i'm
gonna
go for a walk outside because it's good
for my mental health i think just
having more conversations about taking
care of your mental health
is really important right now and it's
an opportunity for kids to practice
different kinds of coping skills
today's kids have their electronic
devices which
can be a double-edged sword for one
right now during the pandemic that's
great they have something
right in their hands that they can use
pretty much at all times
however it also gives them an
opportunity to escape
all discomfort when they're bored they
scroll through their phones when they're
lonely they turn to their phones when
they're tired they pick up their phone
so to be able to set some limits and
teach kids their other coping skills
exist maybe they learn how to
read a physical book maybe they learn to
get some exercise or they pick up a
hobby
they figure out gosh when i'm sad if i
color a picture i feel a little bit
better
and it's not about making kids teaching
them that they have to be happy
all the time it's about teaching them
that when you have an uncomfortable
feeling
you can take care of yourself and this
is how you can do it it's a great
opportunity for parents to experiment
with different coping strategies
yeah absolutely i'm getting a question
maybe it's serious maybe
it's not but people are saying things
what about the advice that whatever
doesn't kill you makes you stronger
which i think is from nietzsche
which i always turn around is you know
whatever doesn't make you stronger kills
you
when i go to the gym that's what happens
yeah i think there's this notion that we
need to toughen people up or we should
all be exposed to horrible things in an
effort to get stronger and i don't think
that's the case i don't think we need to
the more scars we have the stronger we
are we know sometimes people go through
traumatic experiences
and don't necessarily come out stronger
they come out a different person and
that's not
um that's not to say that they are weak
or anything like that but that trauma
changes us so i don't think it's
necessarily true what doesn't kill you
makes you stronger sometimes it changes
who you are and it
leaves some pretty deep scars so i don't
think we need to
toss kids to the wolves just in an
effort to show them that they can
toughen toughen it up or that they can
get through it
what i'm getting a question from one of
my long-term listeners and friends
uh captain captain quinn who's over
there in the uk
staying up late i believe waiting for
saint nicholas he's asking you what do
you find interesting about what brian
keating does which you just met me 10
minutes ago
but do you find anything outside of your
work what do you do to relax
do you look do you watch you know sci-fi
movies are you interested in science
broadly speaking
what kind of things does amy like to do
outside of her awesome work that you
participated
so i live on a sailboat life is like
sort of relaxing
anyway you know i don't really need to
do like yoga to calm down or anything
like that
so for me it's what i find to be
relaxing
or at least what gives me more energy in
life is actually like jet skiing
sailing is kind of slow and quiet and
that's great and all but i'm more of
like i'm going to jump on a jet ski and
go really fast and take some jumps and
fly through the water
so i actually add more excitement to my
life as a way to
make sure that i feel like i'm having
plenty of balance
and during the pandemic i haven't been
able to travel usually i travel a lot
for speaking engagements and i go do
some pretty cool things in different
cities and haven't been able to do that
so it's been more of a challenge to
figure out how do i
add more excitement to my life which for
right now seems to be
jet skiing swimming snorkeling um
stepping off the boat sometimes to go
to go do other things great part about
social distancing when you live on a
boat is my boat moves so i can take my
boat to a reef if i want
or i can i can stay at home while still
traveling
that's awesome wow that's very envious
and i think that's yeah
super super socially distancing um
have you been using this uh some people
are wondering have you been using this
to do more creative work
in the in the same vein so i'll answer
partially for you that you're running a
podcast called mentally strong
which is uh which is one of my favorite
podcasts i should say i find out about
you from your appearance on james
altucher's show
uh and i've been a guest on that uh as
well and
i really just fell in love with the work
that you do and
and i knew i wanted to have you on right
before christmas to help my
my friends of the of the gentile faith
because uh we as i said already endured
the hanukkah
you know extravaganza of of uh mentally
mentally enduring things
and revealing my particular weaknesses
uh i'm getting questions in the chat
about
meditation mindfulness things like that
how do you
uh react to that both for parents and
for kids
uh do you meditate yourself do you
recommend that for children and for
parents
i do so i'm a therapist and i'm big on
figuring out what goes on in our brains
and how do you manage your thoughts
and for people that get into meditation
and mindfulness it's about knowing
that we all have negative thoughts we
all have thoughts that are uh
not helpful sometimes ones that are
filled with self-doubt
we call ourselves names and it's really
about
becoming less less judgmental of
yourself
for thinking weird things or thinking
negative things and
for so many people it just helps them
feel more in control not that they're
controlling every thought that runs
through their head but just knowing they
don't have to react to every thought
that
runs through their minds and so i'm a
huge proponent of mindfulness meditation
for people who want to get started
there's tons of apps out there guided
apps things like that that can help
but certainly isn't for everyone but for
people who embrace it i
haven't found anybody that's really
embraced it for a while and then said
that was a waste of time or that didn't
help instead
i get the opposite people that will say
gosh i was so skeptical at first or i
didn't think that it was going to be
helpful
and at first i didn't think i was good
at it but then they do it for a while
and they say
i'm seeing a big difference and we know
from brain scans that it physically
alters your brain and
uh can help you feel a lot better yeah i
i started to learn how to meditate
myself and i
was spending a lot of time on just you
know um what do you call it just the um
not loving kindness but where you just
think about you clear your mind um
of the visualizations and things like
that and i said well maybe i should go
into transcendental medication and learn
about
that uh and so i went to deepak chopra
who was here in san diego and i said
deepak give me a mantra and by the way
deepak is going to be on the show
and or i'm going to be on his show with
frank wilcheck winner of the nobel prize
whose work i know amy follows in quantum
chromodynamics
uh we'll talk about that some other time
when she if she comes back on but anyway
i went to deepak said deepak gotta help
me out
i need a i need a mantra and he said get
out of here you schmuck
and that's become my mantra shmuck so um
you know
you never know what you're gonna find
when you when you try different modes of
meditating
uh i'm dying to ask you the following
question can you raise a mentally strong
kid
without bribing nagging
raising your voice etc first of all i
feel like i cannot raise my kids and i'm
blessed to have them
uh without some form of bribery either
you know learn piano you know to sit
down take your piano lesson or you can't
watch
15 hours of ipad no i don't let them do
that but um you know the normal bribery
that takes place
is that a bad thing am i how bad of a
parent am i
well you know i guess it depends on how
how we're framing the word bribe i think
most parents
uh i use rewards and rewards are a
really good thing
it bribes can backfire so here's the
difference if you're
in the grocery store and your child says
give me a give them
buy me those cookies and you say
okay here's the cookies you can eat them
now just be quiet you're bribing them
but if you say if you're quiet for the
rest of the
our trip to the store and you don't
scream really loud then you can have a
cookie that's rewarding them
rewards are good we live in a world
where most of us get rewarded you go to
work and then you earn a paycheck your
boss doesn't hand you a paycheck and
then beg you to work for the next week
it happens in the opposite order so i
think by giving kids rewards
and rewarding them for following the
rules whether we reward them with
privileges
or you give them extra incentives you
hand them something that they want maybe
it's cash for doing their chores
uh that just teaches them okay if i want
to earn more responsibility if i want to
have more
respect for my parents if they want to
let me hang out with my friends
unsupervised i have to earn those things
and
by allowing them to earn those things
through their good behavior is a really
healthy thing
yeah that's great yeah thanks um another
thing i wonder about a lot is
i i get a lot of you know kind of um
feedback or i see a lot of my friends
especially my male friends
that are fathers uh raising sons or
daughters and they have this
really you know very friendly
relationship it's really warm to see it
but
you know they call each other buddy or
dude
and sometimes that happens with me i
mean besides you know calling them
affectionate names but uh but is there a
danger
and the familiarity of like all your kid
ever calls you or thinks about you as is
as their buddy
you know judaism uh the word for for
parent
is the same as it has some of the same
roots as the word for the bible itself
which is torah
in hebrew the word for parent is moire
and it's more
for female and it um and essentially
teacher parent and
wisdom are all one word with great
reverence whenever i feel myself saying
oh call me buddy or whatever i seek
parents doing that
is that a negative thing does that
undermine eventually undermine their
authority
it does i think the pendulum swung a
little too far so we had you know back
in the 50s and the 60s where
kids were to be seen and not heard and
father knows best or you called your dad
sir
and sort of like the kids coming out of
that generation we're like oh you know
i know i don't want to do that to my
kids i want us to have a close
relationship but it's almost like they
confused closeness with
saying we're on an equal playing field
and so i'll have parents come into my
therapy office who
are taking a poll they're asking their
kids their 12 year old do you think it's
okay if mom dates again now that we're
your dad and i are divorced and they're
acting as if it's a complete democracy
or they're
asking their kids questions like should
we move across the country so i can take
this job and the eight-year-old is
weighing in as if they have an equal
opinion
and that frightens me because kids
don't want to be in control they don't
want to be in charge they have anxiety
about that of course no eight-year-old
is going to say
give me more rules mom but it's really
rules and boundaries that help kids feel
safe
and there needs to be a hierarchy there
needs to be a parent who says
yeah maybe i i ask you for your opinion
how you feel about something but
ultimately it's up to me to make that
choice
and you don't have to agree with it i'll
help you if you don't agree with it i'll
if you're sad that we're moving or
you're upset that we're
going to be doing something different
this year let's talk about that but you
don't get to be the boss
um but i see a lot of parents that get
that flipped because they somehow assume
in order to be close with their kids
they have to
um let their kids feel like they're on
an equal playing field but i don't think
that's healthy for kids
yeah i definitely agree um so
one other question before i take some
from the audience i want to remind the
audience i'm matching two to one
any donation raised today and through
the super chat and we just got a couple
in
a five pound note from sean thank you
sean so much and i'm gonna ask your
question in just a bit
get priority of those people just
because i want to raise as much money as
possible so i'm personally donating
two to one for every dollar pound
norwegian kroner
uh zimbabwean dollar that is raised
today to amy's favorite charity and one
of my favorite too
called make-a-wish foundation i've
personally known
the children that have benefited it's a
life-saving organization for children
and for parents we're talking about
13 things mentally strong parents don't
do but also let's talk about some things
that
that people don't do mentally strong
people first of all
why did you phrase it in the negative uh
we know from
at least from my religion from from the
judeo-christian religion
there is a difference between positive
commandments you know uh uh
honor thy father and thy mother their
parents
uh and it's both of them and then
there's do not envy you know do not
covet your neighbor's toy that he or she
gets for
for christmas uh why did you phrase it
in the negative what make gives that
so much more power so for me i was a
therapist and i was taught to really
build on people's strengths when they
come in your office
and they have a problem don't
necessarily point out all the mistakes
that they're making but
figure out what they're doing well and
tell them to do more of that so if they
said you know i want to lose weight but
i'm struggling in these three areas but
i eat a lot of vegetables i'm supposed
to say great keep eating those
vegetables and i'm so proud of you
but at some point i realized you know if
i don't tell them to quit eating the
the four cookies before they eat the
salad i'm not doing them any favors
and in my own personal life i
found it easier to have a list of what
not to do when i felt like i was
struggling the most and i went through a
series of losses when i was 23 my mom
passed away suddenly from my brain
aneurysm and it was
the first major loss in my first
experience with with grief
and then on the three years three years
to the day talk about a cruel twist of
fate that my mom died my 26 year old
husband had a heart attack and died
and a few years after that my
father-in-law was diagnosed with
terminal cancer
and i just i remember thinking this
isn't fair i shouldn't have to keep
losing my loved ones i'm
my heart was shattered into a million
pieces
and i wasn't sure even what to do i
didn't know at that moment you know
which way was up which way was down and
i felt so lost
and i wrote a list of what mentally
strong people don't do
because it felt like i could actually
focus on that i didn't need a list of
800 things i should do because i felt so
overwhelmed but i thought if i just
don't do these certain things i'll be
okay
and it was things i had learned over the
years in my therapy office that people
who didn't have certain bad habits got
better
faster they bounced back they still had
hope no matter what they went through
they'd gone through tough times but they
were still working on getting better and
i had realized okay well these people
just don't do these certain things and
other people have a million good habits
but
they have one or two that's sort of
counterproductive and keeps them stuck
and so
i wrote this list it was a letter to
myself and i found it really helpful at
the lowest point in my life
and then i thought if it helps me maybe
it will help someone else
and i put it on the internet and kind of
stepped away thinking
maybe three four people would read it
but 50 million people read that list
and that's when i a literary agent
called and said you should probably
write a book about this
but nobody knew the back story there was
i basically when i published it at first
it was essentially just the list with a
couple sentences about each item
and i was all over the national news and
people were talking about this list and
saying this is amazing and you've
conquered this list well nobody knew
i'd written it because i struggled with
all 13 of those things and so it really
wasn't until the book came out that i
told the rest of the story and
sort of raised my hand and said actually
i struggle with these things too and
it's not that we don't ever do these
things
everyone does them sometimes i guarantee
it but but once they become aware of
them and we focus on not doing them i
feel like then our good habits just
become
so much more effective and i'm a big fan
of saying let's work smarter not just
harder
yeah uh and let's see i'm getting a
question from sean about
sleeping and and how uh
advice for sleeping in these in these
turbulent times
uh well one thing is to read my book
losing the nobel prize that will cure
insomnia instantly but do not read amy's
books
if you want to fall asleep because she
will engage you uh traumatic
dramatically uh amy any advice for sean
and others like
out there who suffer from this this is
particularly pertinent i should say
for astronomers we we have to get to
sleep in very challenging circumstances
i'm planning a video about
how astronomers fall asleep on demand in
challenging places like tops of
mountains and at the south paul
antarctica where i've been
but do you have any tips for these these
turbulent times how do mentally strong
people fall asleep if they don't happen
to have
a gently rocking yacht mega a mega yacht
off the coast of uh the caribbean or
wherever you are
um you know so which it's actually loud
on a boat
it sounds like it's great to sleep on a
boat but there's days and it's not that
easy
but during the pandemic we're seeing a
lot of people struggling with with sleep
issues more than
more than usual and just sort of the
stress of the whole day and so i think
right now it's more important than ever
to take a look at your habits
most of us scroll through our phones
before we fall asleep at night and then
use our phones as an alarm clock to wake
up so we keep our phones next to our bed
that's like the number one thing we
shouldn't do and even though most of us
know this a lot of us do it i'm guilty
of it a lot of the time
but study after study will show that
people who
as an experiment left their phone in
another room at night and then they
asked them in the morning how they felt
people report way less anxiety and most
of the people who do it as an experiment
for 30 days decide to keep that up
because they notice that they sleep so
much better so if i had a number one tip
it would be that it would be to not
sleep with your phone in your room and
don't use your phone in bed
otherwise i think it's about making sure
you get enough exercise during the day
and limiting your caffeine in the
afternoon as i sit here and drink a cup
of coffee but i'm one of those people
that
i could drink a cup of coffee and go to
sleep five minutes later but i know a
lot of people
aren't um and then again just about
daylight
right now as we are in winter and people
in colder climates aren't getting
outside as much and they aren't seeing
daylight we need natural light to
really help our biological clock figure
out when it's night and when it's day i
grew up in maine
and i know when it's dark out at 4 pm
and it's really cold out the last thing
you want to do is
go outside during the day but just
getting some sunlight if you can go for
a walk during your lunch break that can
make a huge difference too
well you're my second guest from maine
in the last few weeks the
previous guest was dr jessica maier who
is
part of the first all-female spacewalk
from the international space station
just just about a year and a half ago
and she's an alumna
of uc san diego and a fellow mainer
and so uh two of you guys wow in one
week that's pretty spectacular
although right there's not that many
people from maine that
i guess uh another say that they've done
cool things like that yeah i guess
another one is
the famous jocko willink who makes this
very beverage that i'm drinking right
now
called uh jocko go he is from maine too
so maine
is he i didn't know yeah he's from maine
he lives in san diego
uh trying to get him on the show uh so
he can you know make me
break me down and then you can come back
and bring me back up again
he's gonna make me physically tough i
hope by drinking jocko go
which i'm not getting paid to plug but i
am getting going to pay
uh to donate to make a wish foundation
two to one for every dollar pound kroner
zimbabwe dollar we got one from my good
friend jay yao
the producer of the of the all
impressive james altriches show and he
is uh
he's one of my heroes and friends jay
i'm using my switcher i hope you get a
lot of good use out of the switcher i
got you
uh as well because uh you're an
inspiration thank you so much jay and
thank you
everybody who is who's opening up your
wallets your digital
your digital bitcoin accounts amy and i
take bitcoin
we take ethereum whatever you want no no
it's all going to be for
make a wish um i want to ask a question
uh as a child of divorced parents myself
and you know having experienced the
trauma of that personally
when when you do talk a lot about in the
book of not overcompensating
and in one sense you know you talk about
yeah this can mommy get remarried
but beyond that i think parents struggle
i think that is certainly extreme and
you want to give your child some agency
but you don't want to um
completely outsource it to him or her on
the other hand it is a kind of a unique
a unique um uh experience for children
to go through
that you know parents don't go through
like adults don't go through like
i'm so traumatized my parents got
divorced when i was you know 49
and actually that's an old joke you know
this couple awaits and they
they get divorced and and i mean it's
it's a horrible i'm not going to say
because it because it's it's
it's it's bad and bad taste but i did
come up with a joke
uh about divorce that it's the most
powerful force in the universe because
it divides your money exactly in half
but we're not going to go there how does
a divorce
you know how do you balance that line
between knowing that the kids are
experiencing something
unique traumatic and and perhaps
you know especially for people of my
generation you're younger than i am but
but
you know a lot of divorce in the 70s and
80s uh what impact does that have
downstream
and you know what about that advice to
to stick it out until the kids get older
what do you think about that
yeah i've seen a lot of parents over the
years that have the attitude of i don't
i'm afraid if we get divorced it'll
traumatize the kids
uh and they don't they don't want to
separate because of that but staying
together when you're sort of miserable
is probably much more detrimental to
your kids than if you
parted ways and divorce doesn't have to
leave deep emotional wounds on kids in
fact the number one indicator of how
kids do when their parents get divorced
is how their parents can get along
and if parents who separate can make a
agreement
we're not going to talk negatively about
each other we're not going to put each
other down we're going to
not necessarily argue about the rules at
your house or how unfair they are
um and when parents can stop trying to
compete to be the
most well-liked or they don't end up
going to courts
repeatedly and changing the custody
situation or asking kids who do you
really want to live with
and when kids are in the middle oh it
can definitely be horrendous
um but when couples are able to do it in
sort of an amicable way
in a way that they can still be kind to
each other
and in a way where they aren't using the
kids as a pawn
often the kids can do can do okay and
you know sometimes i had this one couple
and the parents were really like
concerned that their kid was somehow
going to be scarred for life if they
if they broke up and when they finally
decided that they weren't going to be
together anymore and they asked the kid
what do you think about that and the kid
was all
i guess that means i get two christmases
to which the parents were like wait
is he is he not processing this you know
he must be have some sort of trauma and
they're bringing him in after this
because they're thinking that you know
the fact that he kind of made a joke
about it must meant that he was
really deeply emotionally scarred but
the truth was the kid was just kind of
like well they didn't
really like each other it wasn't a
secret he knew his parents fought all
the time so he was kind of looking on
the bright side and of course it wasn't
to say he was happy about it but on the
other hand it wasn't nearly as bad as
the parents thought so
in the best case scenario is when
parents can say let's figure out how to
work this out i think
kids do do quite well together um and
you know
obviously it's not the easiest thing to
go back and forth between two different
places but kids are pretty resilient
sometimes
and if we support them when they go
through tough times
uh often they'll surprise us with what
they're able to
to really get through one thing i
wondered about listening to your
uh to your book 13 things mentally
strong parents don't do
one of the pieces of advice comes down
to you know don't let your kids beat you
at
chess etc which will appeal appeal to
james
obviously uh altitude he's a chess
master
um but um you know when i'm with my kids
i oftentimes want to
you know maybe maybe it's this
background you know from being primates
you know that
we wrestle and i don't let them just i
don't just destroy them
obviously but i i like to wrestle with
them and i like to give them a challenge
i don't let them win
but um but why shouldn't i i mean if i
if i really go all out obviously i'm not
going to beat me
and you know one of my friends plays you
know really not viciously but he's just
like incredibly aggressive with his sons
and
and really wants them to be tough etc
toughen up uh you you recount an episode
in there i think your aunt
um you know get like oh just walk off
this broken wrist that you
had but why shouldn't i let my kids uh
you know kind of develop some confidence
by
beating daddy at chess i mean what would
that rob them up potentially
yeah you certainly don't have to crush
them because you know every time the kid
goes to play a game with you if they
know they're going to lose really not
that fun anymore but
luckily when you play a game like candy
land you're you don't really have the
advantage anyway because it's just a
game of luck
so you can play those sorts of games
where your kids will beat you sometimes
fair and square
but you definitely don't want to let
them win i see so many parents that
think oh my
my kid can't handle a loss um and or
they let their kid
become a sore loser if the kid's losing
a game and says i don't want to play
anymore they let them
quit and we aren't doing kids any favors
just like they need to learn how to be a
graceful winner it's important for them
to know how to lose gracefully too
and it's okay for them to lose and to
feel disappointed or to be sad sometimes
and
and to talk about it and you know there
probably will come a day where your kid
can beat you at a lot of things at some
point they might run faster than you can
and they may be able to beat you at a
board game
um that's a game of skill and and that's
okay and to know that
but for them to know that for now you've
got more practice you've got more skills
than they do and that's okay and that
they can trust that
mom or dad is competent and capable and
that they're able to do these certain
things maybe that i can't do yet that
actually gives them some confidence too
that you're at the helm of running this
family and
okay you can do some things or you know
you have information i don't have yet
perhaps that's a good thing right
i think kids do need that they need to
know that somebody's in charge
somebody's
driving the boat uh shall we say not to
be too direct to you but yeah that
they need that comfort they need they
need to have boundaries and i think
you know i always say well the first
thing i remember thinking when my kid
was born is i was like
you don't get a big instruction manual
nowadays when you get a smartphone but
you get nothing when you get a kid i
mean one night i was so sleep deprived i
was like
i asked my wife you know give me the
instruction manual like what am i going
to do yeah i work on these here very
complex
you know cryogenic cameras that can see
back to hopefully to the beginning of
time
and it's just like you don't know what
to expect it's it's like reputedly this
advice given or said by
customato the famous mike tyson's
trainer everybody has a plan
until they get punched in the face and i
feel like the advice that people get
as parents you know oh make sure you
catch up on your sleep before the kid is
born i'm like i'm still waiting to learn
how to do that
um and yet uh i wonder is there a sort
of a checklist
in addition to the 13 things mentally
strong parents don't do
is there a way is there a series of
metrics or report card
admittedly i'm a professor so i think in
these terms but is there like a report
how do we know we're doing a good job
while the kids are still
young yeah boy i
i wish there were an exact report card
and we report so much on there how
they're doing in math and
whether they're spelling or they're
reading if they're behind that sort of a
thing but
there isn't a checklist to say that
they're on track emotionally or that
they're doing okay in terms of their
problem-solving skills so it's really up
to parents to kind of figure that out
like okay
compared to the other seven-year-olds is
my seven-year-old able to calm himself
down or is he able to handle
disappointment okay
and so while it's not healthy to compare
your kid to the neighbor kid or to
somebody else's kid you do want to look
around sometimes and think
do the other kids struggle with this are
the other kids making friends are they
able to handle losing
at the kickball game or does my kids
seem to be struggling more than the
average
kid is um and if they're behind in some
way then you just figure out okay how do
i help them with this and all kids
struggle with certain things maybe it's
a certain emotion maybe your kid just
can't handle anxiety so
um they struggle to to sleep or they ask
you the same question over and over
again
um or maybe when they're sad they just
can't pull themselves out of it so i
think it's all about parents just taking
a look at you know what sort of areas
does my kids struggle with in terms of
their emotions in terms of the way they
think
and then in terms of their of the way
that they behave do you have a 14 year
old who's still
poking his brother in the shoulder when
he wants attention because he doesn't
know how else to get it
uh or do you have a say a four-year-old
that
uh you know can't pull himself together
when you tell him that you can't eat
chicken nuggets for dinner and he throws
a huge fit so you need to work on
a few things there um and so i think for
parents to then know what areas
how do i let my kid take on more
responsibility and you do it really
slowly
and then you back off and there'll be
times that you back off a little too
fast and your kid will show you hey
i need more help here there'll be other
times that maybe you are a little too
overprotective
and that will come to light too as long
as you kind of take a step back and
assess where are we
and i spent most of my adult life as a
foster parent and i'd get a call
sometimes at 3 pm and they'd say we're
bringing this kid over at five
i had no idea what to expect and a kid
would show up usually with a trash bag
full of clothes
and i'd get a quick report that would
say well she's been kicked out of the
last 14 places she stayed but she's
really not that bad
and it was usually just a matter of
figuring out okay what skills is this
kid they knew i was a therapist and i
agreed to
take the kids with the worst behavior
problems
what else do they need and sometimes it
was just a few things that needed a
little sharpening and it made all the
difference
in the world so i think for parents to
know when you see these things
in kids it's just a sign that they need
a couple of skills sharpened and if you
can hone in on those things then
it can make a huge difference in their
behavior and how they function
yeah um i'm getting question about uh
from andrew planet uh about martial arts
which but i'm gonna rephrase that you
know obviously
he's saying you know you don't you don't
go all out if you're a black belt in
in karate or krav maga and
and all out on the kids but but um is it
worth you know
kind of exposing kids to to you know
these
potentially life-saving but also
confidence-building types of of
activity sports whatever like the
martial arts is that a positive in your
opinion
it is so as a therapist too i'd have
parents come in and say my kid's really
aggressive is martial arts going to make
them better or worse
and a lot of it depends on where they go
you want to make sure that they have a
competent instructor somebody that's
focused on the self-discipline aspect
not the
aggressive behavior aspect but for a lot
of kids it can be a huge
um can make a huge difference in their
confidence and their physical confidence
but also in their emotional ability to
stay calm
yeah gabrielle williamson is asking do
you have a particular
focus or habit to focus on or not focus
on
for those of us who are dealing with the
loss of a loved one during the holidays
and concomitant with that she's also
asking how did you handle
after your losses you've had so many
losses and you're so
honest and vulnerable it's it's such a
it's you know it's our heart breaks for
you but we also want to learn from you
how did you handle these awful losses
that you experienced especially during
the holidays
yeah the holidays were awful i'll say
the first year after losing a loved one
especially i kind of thought what do i
do after losing my housing i thought oh
how do i
spend this year what do i do with it uh
and for me
i found it was just helpful to come up
with a sort of a new tradition something
different i was going to do
i had somebody tell me like oh just set
up set up put an empty chair at the
thanksgiving table to sort of honor your
loved one
i thought that sounded horribly sad and
depressing and it was the worst thing i
wanted to do but this helped this other
particular person and so
whatever you find helpful for me it was
just about saying let's do something
completely different
and i still sell it the year after i
lost my husband i still celebrated
christmas with his family but we decided
to do
something very different in terms of
what we what we did and how we
celebrated it and that was helpful for
me and so i think
anything you can do to that sounds
appealing for the day
um that's okay and some people might
just ignore the holiday altogether and
if that's what you have to do to get
through the year that's okay too or
maybe you decide
you're gonna light a candle to honor
your loved one but i think just to spend
a little bit thinking about what do i
want to do how do i want this holiday to
look and whatever you decide to do is
completely okay
and in my first book i tell the story
about my husband's birthday
and his mom and i decided to go
skydiving
just to rather than go to work that day
or just stare at the wall we thought
let's go do something kind of crazy and
we've done it every year since not
skydiving but we go on some sort of
adventure to make it a day that we don't
dread but something that we look forward
to so we rode a mule into the grand
canyon one year
and we um went hang gliding another year
but it's something that
she and i still do we didn't get to do
this year because of the pandemic but i
think we'll do it next year but just as
an opportunity to say how do we want to
spend this day and it
was a great way to take back our power
and say let's do something that we
actually want to do rather than allow it
to be a really sad day
yeah i feel like we you know we'd get so
hard trying to be both perfect
you know kind of citizens now we all
have to be epidemiologists we have to
track the data and scientifically and
then we have to be you know healthcare
professionals and
and then go out shopping in a hazmat
suit uh it's
it's incredibly it's incredibly
challenging uh jb patel is asking
um how do you teach accountability and
self-reliance to an 18
to 20 year old so i can't resist saying
you know in my opinion i mean my
oldest is uh is just about 10 but
uh you know i feel like the best time to
discipline your
15 year old is when he's five so
what do you think about the you know
kind of accountability and self-reliance
by the time they get to be
21 you spend a lot of time in the book
mentally strong
parents uh talking about uh you know
when they're young but what do you do
when they're
you know kind of mature and they're in
college yeah it's really tough because a
lot of times parents when kids go away
to college they suddenly think oh gosh i
don't know that i gave them enough
of the skills that they needed to to
function as an adult
i i teach college classes as well and i
can't tell you how many of my college
students their mom and dad call them in
the morning to wake them up
and you know there's a lot of research
too about how many parents these days
are going to their kids job interviews
after they graduate from college and
dads are negotiating salaries moms are
filling out job applications
but by then it's way too late if you're
you can't be waking your 30 year old up
on the phone every morning to get them
to
to go to work every day and so if you
get to the point of between 18 and 21
and you're
starting to panic thinking they don't
have all the skills they need you still
need to back off slowly let them make
some mistakes
natural consequences are some of life's
best teachers
but you have to let them make those
mistakes and that's not to say you
want them to do anything super risky and
dangerous but by now they're adults and
so
if they are going to major in something
you don't like you might have to accept
that if they're going to
spend money on things you don't approve
of it's too late by now you don't you
don't necessarily have the say to
of what they're going to do with their
time their money who they're going to be
friends with
um instead you just want to talk about
if you have a concern bring it up but
don't nag them don't lecture them
because if you want to make sure that
you still have a healthy relationship
with them so that they trust you you're
going to make
need to um to back off and make sure
that they
are able to make those some of those
mistakes on their own
yeah i agree 100 you know it's kind of
this you want to give them some bit of a
life
uh life rope but you don't want to
completely take away all the
all the challenges that they're going to
face or else they won't be
mentally strong parents themselves i
often find that
society sends a mixed message i talked
to nobel prize winner barry barrish
a couple weeks ago and he was saying one
of the worst pieces of advice
people give is about curiosity and kind
of
stifling it he said you know we have
these things like curiosity killed the
cat or
you know don't ask too many questions
and and many of us who are parents know
that
the ultimate answer to almost any series
of questions that are
why why why the ultimate answer is
because i said so
and yet you know does that not take away
their curiosity which
can later in my case lead to you know
potentially stifling my scientific
curiosities
i always say scientists are like
children you know we're very curious
we're full of wonder and imagination we
don't like to play well with others we
are jealous possessive
we don't let to share our toys so
science comes with good our scientists
come with good and bad
characteristics how do you handle the
kind of you know ultimate authority
with also not wanting to stifle their
curiosity
that's a good question and a great point
uh because we do want to let kids
explore
and do things and one of the biggest
mistakes i see parents making is when
their kids are just doing something for
fun and they want to turn everything
into a learning opportunity so when a
kid colors an elephant purple
a mom or dad will say no honey elephants
are gray
or when they're working on something
with the dollhouse and they put the the
bathtub on the roof parents will say no
the bathtub goes in the bathroom not on
the roof
you can let kids play and explore and do
fun things and not everything has to be
about
learning the colors and the numbers and
how we
tend to function as a society instead
you can say wow that's interesting i've
never seen a bathtub on a roof before
tell me more about that
and when you give kids room to to
explore like that i think then they'll
stay curious rather than it's so
tempting sometimes just to be all
or to make them recite back something or
we quiz them when they're just playing
but instead just let them play and play
as part of their work and that's how
they learn and that's also how they stay
curious
yeah absolutely um so the last couple of
questions that i have and then we'll
look for questions from the audience
reminding you that i'm matching two to
one any amount of money donated to
uh the super chat the live super chat
i'm down
matching that two to one for make a wish
foundation so it's a lovely
charity that amy is a huge uh proponent
of as am i
uh so i have a question about uh the
message that society sends oftentimes
uh we'll hear something like you know
well my kid's not quarterback or she's
not
you know captain of the chess club or
whatever but at least she has a good
character
and i always find that extremely harmful
because
the most important thing for me is how
your kid's character is not
you know how great a quarterback he is
or or she's a chess
so i wonder you know why is it that
society puts such a premium on these
things getting into a good college
harvard ivy league you talk about that
uh and the pressure that some parents
put on kids and you talk about the tiger
mom syndrome etc
uh but why do we put so much of a value
on the non-character
things which is actually what matters
most to people that aren't parents of
your own kids
right i think most of it has to do with
the fact that parents are trying to
heal their wounds from their childhood
so the
the dad that never got to be the
quarterback is going to really want his
son to be the quarterback of the team or
the mom who was never popular in school
may really push her
her daughter to be super popular and
studies will show
that for parents that's actually quite
healing when you had a dream and you
weren't able to fulfill it and your kid
does
it's like this moment of your emotional
wound finally
finally getting treated however we know
that's really bad for your kids
so even though it might be good for you
it's really unhealthy for kids to grow
up in that situation where they have
that much pressure on them
or where they feel like your love is
conditional so you don't want to do that
to your kids for sure
and i always encourage parents to get
straight on what your values are to know
exactly
what's more important to you and to ask
yourself would you rather that the
teacher said your kid was the smartest
kid in the class or the nicest kid in
the class
and when you have that answer ask your
kid what they think you would prefer
and you know i'll have so many parents
that say no a strong character is really
important but then their kids are
cheating in school because the kids
think no my parents really value me
getting an a
over all else um so i think it's just
about getting clear on what your values
are and then making sure that you're
communicating those values to your kids
yes absolutely okay so we're getting
some more questions in the live chat let
me pull those
up over here uh okay
um so james
savage is asking isn't divorce linked to
decline of trust in institutions
in other words doesn't the pain of
divorce transcend the emotional impact
of the end of a marriage
yeah you know i think when we look at
some of the studies on the long-term
data for kids and the outcomes we know
that
when kids have parents who are divorced
sometimes then it affects their
relationships as adults so it's not to
say that
divorce doesn't cause kids great pain
but i think we need to look at the
the pain of living with parents who
aren't necessarily in love with each
other too and the effect that can have
on them
but the actual institution of marriage i
would say you know people
talk about how you know 50 of marriages
end in divorce and isn't it kind of
going one of my friends calls you know
marriages pre-divorces i mean he's got a
dark sense of humor
but uh but the uh but the but the point
being you know is the institution of
marriage when kids see other kids maybe
it's less prevalent i don't know what
the current stats are but
certainly when i was a kid as i
mentioned in the 70s and 80s it was very
prevalent
and so maybe uh what he's wearing
learning about is is the institution
itself
you know kind of undermining itself and
do do kids get attuned to that like when
they're maybe their parents aren't
getting divorced you talk about
you know a child learning that his uh
father has diabetes i believe in the
book
and but the parents saying you know well
that doesn't mean he's gonna die just
because it says the word die in diabetes
um so yeah i guess these kinds of you
know children are so much more
perceptive than we give them credit for
and i think you know the delicate
balance is really the hardest thing to
do
i think so and i think in today's world
you know the whole marriage ideas
is quite different than it was uh you
know 20 30 years ago there's plenty of
kids whose parents were never married
maybe they still live together they just
have never
made it legal or there's plenty of kids
whose mom and dads you know
had a quick brief relationship and
they've never been married either so i
think
there's not the same stigma attached to
it maybe then 30 years ago where if a
kid's parents got divorced maybe it was
embarrassing or
and there might be one kid in the class
whose parents weren't divorced but i
think it's
really changed now in terms of who's
married who isn't and kids aren't
maybe don't even know that that's your
stepdad or that's not your biological
dad or your parents aren't legally
married
uh i want to ask you when you're you
have your this ted talk that went
completely viral it's one of the most
popular most seen videos of all time on
ted
uh tedx and we have a link to it in the
in the
video description how did you react just
as a person forgetting about the
the work and the and the and the actual
topic how did you actually react to that
incredible burst of attention and
and really fame uh you know for such a
worthy
worthy person worthy cause but just on a
personal level how did that affect you
yeah i was so nervous giving that talk
my my voice cracks the entire time and i
remember stepping off the stage thinking
i just gave a talk about mental strength
and i sounded like i was terrified and
the last thing i
it was just like i hope nobody ever
watches that and
and at first nobody did it was like a
really slow
growing thing and so for you know for
the first couple of months a few people
watched it and i thought whew
kind of got out of that one and then it
grew and then it started growing and
it's kept growing and so it's been five
years but
to this day about 10 000 people a day
watch it i can't quite fathom that
number
um but you know and it's and now that
it's like 15.5 million people have seen
it and so
you know i called a photographer to take
some headshots and she's all i've seen
your ted talk
and so it's it's an interesting place to
be to think that
that many people i can't even fathom
what 15 million people looks like so
it's
um it's been a surreal experience to
have that many people uh hear my story
or sometimes people will buy my book and
they won't put two and two together
until they read a little bit about my
story and then they say
i i know i watched your talk so now i
know who you are
well certainly uh i got got a lot of
attention to someone that's deserving
well deserving of it and uh it's really
a phenomenal i couldn't tell
that you were nervous i i know it's
natural to be nervous but you didn't
know how many people be watching it i
mean that's basically
the size of uh you know decent-sized you
know baseball stadium
every week as are people watching it for
the first time
i want to close out with a couple
questions uh that i wondered about uh
not to i hate it when authors come on
podcasts or when i was going on podcast
and the host would say you know tell me
about your book everything about it your
argument
and uh everything that people can do and
take away from it so that they don't
have to buy it
it's a service i'm doing for my
listeners is relieving them of the
obligation of buying uh a book no but uh
but i do want to ask in terms of if you
could say
the top two takeaways that mentally
strong people don't do what would they
be
so i think the first one would be um
which is number one in the book that
they don't waste time feeling sorry for
themselves and
this one the biggest misconception is
people tend to think that
uh that feeling sorry for yourself is
the same as being sad but those are two
really different things that it's okay
to
to be sad but self-pity is when you
start to exaggerate how bad your life is
when you think it's awful you get to be
hopeless and helpless
so allow yourself to be sad that can
help you honor something you lost but
when you cross over into self-pity to
become aware of it and refuse to do it
and the second one would be not to give
away your power um
we tend to give other people so much
power in our lives sometimes we'll say
like oh my
mother-in-law makes me feel bad or my um
my boss
um criticizes me and i and i question my
ability to do my job well
you're giving so many people power over
the way you think feel and behave and
uh taking back that power is about
saying i'm an adult it's my
choice and somebody else might criticize
me but i don't have to make that
i don't have to feel bad about myself or
somebody else might offer their opinion
of what i should do with my life but i
don't have to listen
interesting very good uh well amy this
has been a great a joy i do want to
point people
to uh your podcast mentally strong uh
mentally strong people
which is available everywhere we get
podcasts and
it's on my my must download list of uh
pods that i
catch every week i don't know how you do
it from the boat but i'm interested in
learning your technology and becoming
one of your students uh
as well actually before i have a good
audio i have a really good audio
engineer that's my secret
oh yeah is it j is it j.e.o yeah he
isn't but we've consulted with jay
me too join the club jay is phenomenal
um
i just want to close in the context of
being students uh the last thing i want
to talk about i get this a lot as a
college professor
which is uh which is you know this new
this these two new phenomena of grade
grubbing
and grade inflation and they kind of
work work at opposite ends or work to
support each other depending on how you
look at it
how should we deal with this uh in the
context of educators
and people who aren't parents but play
sort of a a mentorship
role towards uh towards young people how
do we balance the grade grubbing
you talk about you know your first
experience with grade grubbing and
and the emotional blackmail that the
student put you under i felt i felt
terrible for you
but how do you deal with that as a
mentor or educator not necessarily a
college professor like the two of us
you know i think it's about knowing that
again it goes back to that pressure that
sometimes we put on young people that if
you get one b
you're not going to get into an ivy
league college so therefore we have to
make sure that you get a get straight
a's at all costs and it's about letting
go of that and it's about letting kids
know that you can let kids fail and the
message shouldn't be that you're too
awesome that you'll never fail but it's
instead that you'll fail sometimes but i
know you're strong enough that you can
handle it
and that we don't do anyone any favors
when we when we start inflating their
grades or when we start
playing around with the numbers just to
make it look good that
we can really let them earn whatever it
was that they got and have conversations
about that and that we don't want them
to think that
that's how the world works your boss
isn't necessarily going to
you know promote you or do things just
because you
claim you deserve it or um because
nobody else got the work done so somehow
that's going to be helpful to you so i
think it's really about letting kids
fail teaching them that yeah life isn't
always fair but we're not going to
artificially promote you either just
because because you
think you deserve it or because you're
the one that cries the loudest about
your grade
that's right so you're not really doing
them any favors if you were to do that
um
well amy i want to thank you so much for
being so gracious with your time and uh
in this
hectic time of the year and for
everybody i want to thank you for
writing wonderful books
and look forward to your book on kids
book what's the title of it i know it's
available on amazon for pre-order what
what's the title of your upcoming book
for children
so the new one is called 13 things
strong kids do
i didn't want to make it part of the
don't do series because kids don't want
to be told what not to do but hopefully
if we give them
these skills and tools when they're
young they'll grow up and
avoid the 13 things mentally strong
people don't do
well i will tell people to go out there
and please do order
all of amy's books even the ones that
say don't but order those pre-order the
kids book i'm certainly going to be
doing that
thank you so much for joining us on this
chat from uh from wherever you
are and helping us get through what will
surely be
a challenging uh next couple of weeks
both with the pandemic
and with the holidays and kids not
getting what they want
and even getting what they want oscar
wilde said you know one tragedy in life
is
is getting uh is not getting what you
want and the other is getting it
uh so hopefully uh people will get what
they want what they deserve and what
they need
and uh remember what the rolling stone
said you can't always get what you want
but you get what you need
this is brian keating with amy morin
who's the author of so many wonderful
books today we spoke mostly about her
mentally strong parents
and i want to advise people to please
tune in over the coming weeks we're
going to be having
more great guests and nobel prize
winners but also some people
in the in the uh what do they call them
soft sciences amy
how do you describe what you do um yeah
i guess we could call it a soft science
absolutely so i like to balance the hard
with the soft so we'll have uh
we'll have uh people like john preskill
on the hard sciences
and we're gonna have uh a woman who
wrote a wonderful book allison
schechter i think is her name it's
called an economist walks into a brothel
so tune in for that that is coming up
soon
in january everybody thank you so much
for going into the impossible with me
your fearful host brian keating less
fearful now because of amy
please do subscribe exercise your finger
amy will tell you
uh it's important not to get carpal
tunnel syndrome so please exercise your
finger
hit subscribe hit like and leave a
comment in the
in the chat about what you took away
from this episode i learned so much from
it and from all of amy's books
amy be well happy holidays and hope to
talk to you again sometime in the next
year thank you i hope so too
bye guys